these pains you feel are messengers
listen to them
we carry inside us the wonders we seek
outside us
only from the heart can you touch the
sky
wherever you are and whatever you do
be in love
the moment you accept what troubles
you've been given the door will open
your heart knows the way run in that
direction
you are not a drop in the ocean
you are the entire ocean in a
drop as you start to walk on the way the
way appears
silence gives answers
whatever lifts the corners of your mouth
trust that
my soul is from elsewhere i'm sure of
that
and i intend to end up there
yesterday i was clever so i wanted to
change the world
today i am wise so i am changing myself
be like a tree and let the dead leaves
drop
it's your road and yours alone
others may walk it with you but no one
can walk it for you
in the blackest of your moments wait
with no fear
maybe you are searching among the
branches for what only appears in the
roots
i am not this hair
i am not the skin
i am the soul that lives within
close your eyes fall in love
stay there
what you seek is seeking you
life is a balance of holding on and
letting go
raise your words not your voice
it is rain that grows flowers not
thunder
the soul has been given its own ears to
hear things the mind does not understand
when you do things from your soul
you feel a river moving in you a joy
if all you can do is crawl
start crawling
patience is the key to joy
if light is in your heart you will find
your way home
set your life on fire
seek those who pan the flames
[Music]
i know you're tired but come this is the
way
respond to every call that excites your
spirit
[Music]
you were born with wings
why crawl through life
patience with details makes perfect a
large work like the universe
work keep digging your well
water is down there somewhere
love sometimes wants to do us a great
favor
hold us upside down and shake all the
nonsense out
concentrate on the essence
concentrate on the light
death is not going away
the sun sets the moon sets
but they are not gone
why do you stay in prison when the door
is wide open
ignore those who make you fearful and
sad that degrade you back towards
disease and death
gamble everything for love if you are a
true human being
half-heartedness does not reach into
majesty
conventional opinion is the ruin of your
soul
let go of your mind and then be mindful
close your ears and listen
the desire to know your own soul
will end all other desires
oh happy is the soul that sees its own
faults
when you lose all sense of self the
bonds of a thousand chains will vanish
everything about yesterday has gone with
yesterday
today we need to say new things
love risks everything and asks for
nothing
whatever happens just keep smiling and
lose yourself in love
when we practice loving kindness and
compassion
we are the first ones to profit
if you love someone you are always
joined with them
in joy in absence in solitude in strife
now i am sober and there's only the
hangover and the memory of love
[Music]
travel brings power and love back into
your life
why should i be weary when every cell of
my body is bursting with life
when you feel a peaceful joy
that's when you are near truth
don't make yourself miserable with what
is to come or not to come
when setting out on a journey do not
seek advice from those who have never
left home
[Music]
i learned that every mortal will taste
death
but only some will taste life
be kind and honest and harmful poisons
will turn sweet inside you
if you want money more than anything
you'll be bought and sold your whole
life
[Music]
friendship of the wise is good
a wise enemy is better than a foolish
friend
if you are looking for a friend who is
faultless you will be friendless
be with those who help your being
[Music]
the intelligent desire self-control
children desire candy
i am a child whose teacher is love
surely my master won't let me grow to be
a fool
don't grieve anything you lose comes
back in another form
the wound is the place where the light
enters you
one of the marvels of this world
the sight of a soul sitting in prison
with the key in his hand
don't get lost in your pain
know that one day your pain will become
your cure
be patient when you sit in the dark the
dawn is coming
suffering is a gift in its hidden mercy
greed makes man blind and foolish and
makes him an easy prey for death
prayer clears the mist and brings back
peace to the soul
our greatest strength lies in the
gentleness and tenderness of our heart
the fault is in the one who blames
spirit sees nothing to criticize
that which is false troubles the heart
but truth brings joyous tranquility
wear gratitude like a cloak and it will
feed every corner of your life
the only lasting beauty is the beauty of
the heart
shine like the whole universe is yours
if you wish to be a mine of jewels open
the deep ocean within your heart
truth lifts the heart
like water refreshes the soul
[Music]
silence is the language of god
all else is a poor translation
[Music]
stay in the spiritual fire
let it cook you
all religions all this singing
one song
peace be with you
i am in the house of mercy and my heart
is a place of prayer
you